Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to-
(Clearing throat) Mm, "Best played with a controller"
That's not a good sign.
Oooh, I am about to die horribly in horrible ways.
I... Oh boy...
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Manual Samuel.
The game you guys want me to play because you want me to get very angry.
I saw a preview of this game,
and it seems like the exact type of game that's gonna make me very angry.
(Smiles away the future pain)
So we're gonna have a great time playin' Manual Samuel if this is fuckin'. (Muttering)
God da- I PLUGGED IT IN!
Do I gotta restart the god damn (inhale) OH we're off to a great start.
Okay! Hello! Welcome to Manual Samuel!
The game you guys want me to play 'cause i'm gonna rage a whole lot.
I've already said that, but i'm saying it again just in case I don't decide to use that first intro,
but something tells me I will.
Bang.
So.
(Lip smacking)
From what I can understand- Oh god Co-op.
I can't imagine that..
From what I understand,
This is like some sort of physics based.
(Inhale)
Do-your-own-dangle-thing-you-can't-control-your-god-damn-body Sorta deal.
But it's a story based game apparently!
I don't know a lot about the story,
or what the story's gonna even be about, but I know it's about a guy-
Oh!
Uh huh.
Oh, uh we're not doing that?
Oh okay.
Oh.
Oh, the humor of this game..
Mm.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh!!
Jesus.
(Mark making blinking noises?)
Oh.
(Bored) Huh.
Mm. (understandingly)
Mm. (angrily)
Mmm! (I don't know anymore)
(Mark copies Vault Guy)
Ah.
OH.
OW.
Why, I don't think physical violence was warranted!
Oh jeez-
Not really, his eyes are open.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay...
I'm ready.
Oh no.
Oh.
(Giggles)
Oh!
Ah!
Oh, sorry!
Pardon me!
(Markipoo Giggles at the violent action)
(Laughing)
Uh-
(Mark, Why did you attack this poor boy?)
Ah-I don't know!
But i'l leave your political satire for something else-
I'm still learning out to be huuuman~
Woah- kay.
Hey- whah.
Am I supposed to go that way?
Woahbitty-Hibbity-Hobbity
So I had some misconceptions about what this game is,
And I want to apologize in advance because it seems a lot more interesting and fun.
Wee bada doo ba de~
Hey how you doin'?
Wooaaup.
(500 Eur = 557.10 USD)
Euros?
Wow.
(Cashier now has 1114.20 USD)
Oh! Yay!
(Mark throwing sounds)
(1671.30 USD)
I-I think it may have been the traumatic brain injury that I had,
But also because i'm a rich, spoiled brat.
(British accent) You want more money?
( Cashier = 2228.40 USD Richer)
Ey, I like this guy.
He's not so bad- Also why is there a picture of me in the back behind my rich parents?
And my mother with dead eyes.
(Mark, You could've used this money to buy games!)
(totally tubular voice) Woahhh
OKAY BYE~
..YOU'RE WELCOME.
Huueh- Can I still hurl money at the empty counter?
Hey!
Want my money?
Okay, alright, g'bye then.
Hubu du bub, baduba~
Be beduba bedubub~
Hepoo bedebeboop.
Let me just-
Let me just slap your table once or twice
That was a good- That was a good table
Lemme get the FEEL of that.
Ah.
That's nice. Hey.
You want 'a hundreds? (One hundreds)
Did you want FIVE hundreds?
I've got lots of five hundreds. (Mark, you spent your allowance...)
Yeah, I could slap something else down on this table...
(Unintelligable sexy muttering)
Okay, i'm on my way!
(Mark singing a Jibberish tune)
Can I- Can I just-
Can I stop doing the moon walk for one second and hurl a 500 dollar bill at this door here-
Nope!
Right mouse.
It's a tutorial-
Yeah, okay.
Caused by a-- an abusive girlfriend
AH-
J-Jamie!
J-Janison!
You don't know that!
I mean probably I should considering she whacked me upside the head with a bottle and that's sup- (Narrorator Cuts off Markie)
Oh god.
(Markiplier makes fish lips)
Well alright then!
Yeah you should be shocked!
But I Don't imagine you're gonna be that upset, considering you almost broke mah brain!
Oh jeez, oh god-
What is happening in this game? (Giggles)
This game is much more delightful than I ever could have imagined.
I thought I was- I thought it was going to be a rag doll runners type.
Horror show.
Oh my god.
Well.
Alright then, that's it. Alright, Samuel's story is done.
We're outta here.
Oh, okay.
Perfectly Paranormal presents: Manu-
Oh my god! This game is actually gonna be cool!
Wow!
I can't believe- I was putting this off
I was putting it off until I'd have
time enough to rage my brain out.
A-and the pleasant surprise is I'm gonna have a great time with this game!
Oh, I can't believe it!
This is wonder- you guys don't understand how happy I am.
I was getting ready to be so mad. (Never Judge a book by it's cover, Mark!)
Oh god yes.
Oh, the Charon Express.
I get that that's some reference to the
underworld of some type but either way.
Wait, isn't Charon a celestial body
probably named after some sort of old
god or demon or place in the underworld or something like that.
Oh joyous day.
Oh frabjous day!
Callooh! Callay!
(Mark Moans.)
I didn't but it's a boon for me.
Uh.
Oh. (painfully)
Oh geez.
You just had to be a dick didn't ya?
Whelp, time to remember how to get up
*hur-be-dir-gid-de-bur*
Maybe if I slap the ground a bit more it's gonna be a little more beneficial to me.
Also why am I in outer hell?
Okay then.
Well.
Huh.
*struggling*
What the-
*more struggling*
Wel-Ouh?
Huh. (Mark is not suprised)
Wow.
Okay.
Probably don't know what they are.
Okay, I don't hear any screaming souls.
Aww, have a nice day? Thank you you're like
the guy from Sort the Court, aren't you?
You...
Oh, so are those bodies careening t- Oh.
Is that a dog under your- Oh, it's a hat.
Oh.
Is it a phat rhyme?
Oh boy.
Okaaay?
I didn't do anything!
Wha?
Oh.
Okay...
I'll just be skedaddlin' on my way.
Don't mind me- Oh hi.
*giggling*
Oh god! Oh god, no!
Wait, hang on.
Might think about something here.
Sir I don't understand the concept of
punishment here
what's over here
Ahhh
Oh god. No.
Oh
*Chuckling*
Also, why was the
meaning of life a single sperm?
Oh, alright then
bye thought I was going to get
interesting story
Okay, *muttering*
Oh, I'm
starting to like this i was already
predisposed to hate this game but now.
*giggling*
Wait
How do I know I'm going to need that?
Does the concept of a year apply down here?
What does that mean?
Okay, so it was just one shred of life and
got me back up in the living situation
I guess? i actually really like this game *Giggles*
Oh God
Oh jeez
Oh jeez *giggling*
Yeah!
NO!
I Bre- I don't know how to breathe apparently.
I'm trying to blink.
*babbling*
No!
Mhm, jeez
Oh, jeez
oh geez yes
YES!
*Giggling*
I mean all *giggles*
Oh, jeez
Oh thanks death, you're so cool.
Oh jeez. Oh jeez
Alright, you do a kickflip
Oh, god dammit
Oh, no.
Oh boy, now I can see, maybe I
spoke too soon about enjoying this game.
*Cackling?*
Oh, I'm having a great time.
Oh jeez
oh boy, oh god, oh boy wait that's not the
bathroom is it.
Ah jeez.
*Mark makes a mini-orgasm*
(Under Breath) Uh, Jeez..
*Chuckles*
(Calm Down time) Ohh..
I don't know man come on, lay off
I'm, aw god.
Alright, you keep trying Death *giggling*
*Giggles intensify* Oh, Uh, Jesus.
oh god, ah sh-
Okay, I'm gonna make it.
I'm unna' make it.
Eventually
I know, shut up narrator I'm really trying here
god I just can't catch my breath
Ugh.
DO I?
I'm really trying here
it's hard to breathe. Apparently... oh-okay
Now we got it
Hep. Blink blink. Breathe. Step... step, turn.
Breathe. Breathe. Alright.
Oh, jeez
Hah.
Uh...
*Babbles* Blink, blink, blink.
Breathe.
*Laughing*
Hah!
*Laughs*Jesus!
*Laughs*
Whoo, alright, *babbling*
PUAH!
Blink, blink, blink. Blink. Ok. God, this is gonna be so difficult.
Grab! Brush, brush, brush, brush, spit.
Breathe, spit.
OW!
God...
Hic!
Brush, brush, brush, brush spit breathe breathe
breathe blink-blink blink-blink breathe
*Multiple brushes*
Oh god dammit!
Hep! Heh! Hah! Ok.
*Heavy breathing
I could just lay on the floor, I--I could
just lay on the floor an--
I--
I was..
I was in the middle of the breathing thing!
Okay, if I hold in my breath
apparently that works just a little bit--
God dammit.
Aaagh...
Hep. Ok...
You're up! (Maybe Europe?)
Ok, I got a full breath!
*Babbling*
God dammit, if I just keep my mouth open and just suck air
eternally inside my body
nothing can stop me
Really? Ok dammit abba-dabba dupa don't mind my
zombie-like trance
oh my spine broke the wrong way too much
momentum that was probably my problem
i'm a bit dirty from experiencing all
that Hell had to offer me .
*weird noise.*
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to... Oh God. eh.
Don't mind me
Don't mind me! Don't mind me, Death
It's okay. Do I still need to breathe?
I probably still need to breathe... I mean
I'm assuming my parents will forgive me
if i get pissed all over the place also
do they come in here and clean so they
wouldn't even be worried about this--AAWW
God dammit, my spine
Yay! i'm a perfect peeer not a perfect
Walker just yet but peeing
that's my mainstay yeah let me just grab this
Yup, let me just just Kinda.. Do a little...
*Babbling* I'm so clean yes blink, blink, blink
I should probably close my eyes for this
shouldn't I? Or else this is gonna burn
yeah there we go. I'M SMART! Look at
how smart I am!
whoa-oh multitasking and keeping my eyes
fresh and clean
okay what else do i need to do clean my
hands? aww, look at me go! Yay!
Oh look at me up- god damn it haba
haba haba haba haba haba. Just wait till my
spine breaks... ow... there we go
*Glitchy babbling* breathe
Breathe *More Glitchy Babbling*
uh-huh where would those be?
Shit, here?
oh nice, so smart meam meam do(?)
I don't know maybe
clothes? Don't mind me let me let me live my
life dammit
Alright, what's over here? oh, nice art of me
I'm so beautiful it's a good thing I
take care of this incredible b-ow
I don't know, I don't know what kind of clothes I have
err... whats in bee're?
Anything over bee're?
No?
how bout-
That sounds stupid, who would even do that?
Who would wear pants in the first place?
That sounds dumb.
heh... one leg at a time, am I right.
*gibberish*
Okay? what about an undershirt first?
y- you might wanna be worried about that.
Okay, how bout you go- *laughs*
I almost had that.
Let me just... get... there we go, left.
vrrip... vrrip...
Yay!
Yay.
Okay, where are my shoooes?
Anybody found any shoes ova here.
Shoooeses.
Ow! okay.
Can I put them- a- aw *gibberish*
Nice
Thanks for having so much confidence and a lot of sarcasm for me, Announcer-Boo!
Do I get to carry on with my life, now?
*Babbling*
Oh, stairs.
(One small step for man..)
(One Tumble for man-kind.)
Ugh--pffft!
*Giggling*Oh, jeez!
Oh.
Whoopsies. *Giggling* Oopsie poopsies!
That was my bad. Ok, here we go!
Herp--OW.
Herp-a-derp-a-derp-a-derp, don't mind Samuel, he is manual.
Get out of the way.
How 'bout fuck you.
I'm gonna play.
Cant I...?
Eh.
Nope, that ain't worki--
WELL.
OH.
Okay... gonna--gonna go now.
Hey, Death.
How ya doing?
Yep, that's me--Ow. Do--ignore that.
I'll be on my way, now. GOODBYE.
Gotta go out my front door and live my life.
You know...
As anyone would.
This house is big.
Oh, God.
Alright, then.Thanks Mom.
Herp.
Ugh, shit.
Uah, fuck.
Welp. Shitty tits, that didn't work at ALL.
Ok, blink blink blink, breathe.
Breeathe.
Pick up.
This says left bumper but...
God dammit.
EYEH.  *A bunch of noms*
PUEH.
*Giggles.*
Rip.
Okay.
Herp.
*More noms.*
This is delicious apparently.
Oh, shit.
Ok, got this.
Rup.
Whoops.
Hep.
Ok, breathe, breathe.
Ok.
Do I need to eat any more?
Blink blink blink blink.
*Noms*
Yaaay!
How much more do I need to eat?
Nothing? There's nothing left. Nevermind, I guess I'm good.
*Weird noises.
I'm ready.
I'm ready. (Markiplier is now Copying Spongebob.)
I'm ready--you'd think the maid would've cleaned up a bit.
Ooooooh, hey.
Oh, boy...
Ugh.
Ee.
AAH!
*while laughing* Oh, jeeze.Oh, God.
*giggling*oops.
That was my bad.
Haha!
Ooh. Uh- huh.
Blurb.
Yaaay!
Ah, fuck.
EH.
I DID IT!
HELL YEAH!
Ow.
Yep, that sounds like me.
Herp-a-derp-a-derp.
Oh, god, there's the game machine!
BYYYYEEE.
Oh, jeeze, where's it going?
Oh, jeeze, I gotta keep up with that.
Where's it going?
Where are you going?
Where are you going, machine?
Machine?
AAAUGH, DUDE, MY CAR.
Well, bye...
Why do you have to drive with me? Ok. Alright, then.
So, anyway.
I am out of time, but this game was an incredibly pleasant surprise.
I am going to wait
for the rest to decide if I actually want to do more episodes of this.
But this game is really funny and--and really fun to play, so I might play more of it.
So...
Thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you thought down in the comments below.
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video.
Buh-byyyee!